[Music]
[Music]
what did you do this weekend Diana
nothing very interesting
warrior of the Amazons daughter of zoo
and protector of the world she grew up
isolated from the world of men to super
smart super sophisticated full of hope
she's the most talented warrior but at
the same time doesn't care for the fame
or for the glory
she partners with Batman to unite the
need we're asking people we don't know
to risk their lives I know how this
works
she's this glue to the team
she makes each and every one of them
feel stronger and capable
he said the age of heroes who never come
again
[Music]
just the end of the world too
you can't save the world amount we do
this together
Island
[Music]
long before I was born he came as the
spearhead of an alien invasion which
made me see
we have families what does everyone keep
telling me
there are enemies coming from far away I
need more
just like that you really are out of
your mind I'm not the one who brought a
pitchfork
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't recognize this way
to recognize it
[Music]
we just have to save it
ride ain't over yet my man
you
you